let's get Labor's take on the morning's
stories and their Shadow House of
Commons leader I think I'm Debonair
joins us in the studio lovely to see you
this morning let's start shall we with
with teacher strike just that was
Jillian Keegan was talking about that
the problem from the teaching Union
seems to be look we have had a stretch
in our budgets for for many a year now
you're asking us to find more money I
mean Jillian Keegan says that there is
more money available because the cost of
energy has come down I mean if the maths
add up do you think this is a deal that
should be accepted well I think there's
that there's the question if the math
Fed Up and certainly schools I talked to
in Bristol are telling me that at the
moment that's not how they feel they
don't feel convinced and teachers need
to feel convinced and school leaders
need to feel convinced because they've
had years of having their budgets really
stretched under successive Tory
government so if Julian Keegan says it's
true she needs to work harder to
convince the teaching units and teachers
and schools across the country it's
because of course we all want teachers
back at work and you know they are hard
at work today but we want to make sure
that they don't feel pushed to the edge
and need feel that they need to consult
on taking more industrial action but
just to be absolutely clear then an
offer of 4.5 percent plus the thousand
pounds payment that would be acceptable
to you if it is Affordable within the
budget we need to know that it's
affordable within the budget any
responsible government would and a labor
government would be making sure that
this doesn't put additional strain on
already stretched schools budgets and
that is really important and and I think
that is really clear it can't be coming
out of existing School budgets there are
huge concerns of course about what is
going on in the health service at the
moment Junior doctors don't even appear
to be in negotiations nurses have been
given have been given a final offer what
do you think of the Royal College of
Nursing having having looked at the deal
recommending it to their members the
members then voting against it well I
really understand why members feel
really fed up and feel pushed to the
edge now there was a recruitment crisis
before the coronavirus we then had
nurses and other NHS staff putting their
literally their lives on the line for us
for three years and before Christmas
when industrial action was in the in the
wings the head of the nursing Union Pat
Collins said to the government she would
negotiate anywhere anytime including
Christmas Day Steve Barkley the health
secretary Rishi soon at the Prime
Minister failed to do anything about it
so no wonder they feel pushed but there
isn't there is no point to any further
negotiation given the fact that you know
the RCN said actually no this is a deal
that we can recommend to our members and
the members said no so I mean it's it's
time to the union to saw this one
actually there's always room for further
negotiation and I really think even at
this late stage Rishi soon at least to
come down and sort this out that would
be a responsible leader that will be
what we're streeting if he was Health
secretary would do it's what Kia Stormer
would do but we would also we would also
not have been in this position in the
first place under the labor government
between 1997 and 2010 total of NHS
strikes was zero and that is because we
kept talking to the workforce now that
is the sign of this Tory government
that's on them that's their failure to
talk to the nursing unions in advance
and actually try and sort things out to
prevent the industrial action sure I'm
just wondering what where's treating
could do more than Steve Barkley given
that the deal was accepted by the union
but rejected by the membership I mean
what what more can be said about it
Peter met the months ago he'd have been
talking to them months ago he would have
been listening to them he would have
been shown them that they have valued he
would have been shown that he understood
their concerns which are not only pay
they include pay which in a cost of
living crisis you can't blame them but
they are also about the conditions under
which they are working now we want to
help deal with those conditions by
investing in the biggest NHS Workforce
expansion in its history and that's what
we're streeting would be doing and we're
not hearing that from this government
and we're not hearing it from Rishi Zuna
to be absolutely clear though if if
emergency care if Cancer Care is not
protected by the Royal College of
Nursing which is which is something that
is being discussed would labor be in a
position to condemn the strike action
well when we're not we we wouldn't
support withdrawing Cancer Care and
emergency care and I don't think nurses
and doctors want to do that I think that
this is why it's on Rishi soon now to
get down and sort this out
it's really easy for you to say this but
but the shadow Health secretary was
shooting called on Steve Barkley to show
leadership but he himself can't give the
junior doctors what they wanted he
himself admitted explicitly that 35 that
they are asking for it's a non-starter
but going to talk to them is how you get
through this nothing ends without
resolution nothing ends without talking
it's not going to help patients it's not
going to help doctors and and I really
think that rishis unit needs to see that
if he really wants to if he really means
that his priority of cutting waiting
times that he takes it seriously he
needs to show some leadership get down
and talk to them as Western would be
doing and as kirstan will be doing under
a labor government what do you make a
Rishi soon actually plans this morning
to be honest later on this morning to
have everyone studying math until the
age of 18. look I'm I'm genuinely not
going to be quizzing anyone this morning
on their maths I'm ready I'm ready it
would be somewhat hypocritical of me to
do so
um but but it sounds like a good idea
doesn't it oh it's but it's it's not
even a new idea and it's not even a plan
it's like we'll have another
consultation he announces I think back
in January wasn't it another time when
he wanted to distract from something
that was going on over here he announced
that over there it's a non-plan it's
really really poor what we actually need
seriously these teachers but we need
teachers that's the plan Rishi soon like
he needs the one that needs to add up I
mean the labor government we would if we
were in power we would be investing in
6500 new teachers and we would do that
by scrapping the charitable status of
private schools that's the sort of tough
decision that kirstama would be taking
Bridget Phillipson who's our shadow
education secretary has rightly
condemned this as just yet so much more
flannel it's just nonsense a couple of
things I want to get through quite
quickly and one which I think a lot of
people will look at and describe as as
nonsense as well and that's the attack
advert and that was directed at Rishi
sunac where it says in you know quite
clearly that Rishi sunak thinks adults
convicted of sexually assaulting
children should not go to prison do you
genuinely believe that well a way of
Rishi seen that showing us that he does
want to do something about the rate of
conviction of child sexual assaulters is
by doing something about it he doesn't
even have cutting crime as well if his
five priorities five priorities none of
them in crime do you believe that
statement to be correct I've got to
judge him on his actions and where are
his actions there's been a court backlog
before the coronavirus crisis this is
the Prime Minister of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland would prefer to see
sexual we have vendors not in prison we
have to judge people on their actions he
is the prime minister of the country he
has had months to take action on a court
backlog that predates the coronavirus
crisis that's the result of successive
Tory government policies Rishi Suna
can't just distance himself from
previous Tory governments and just wash
his hands of any responsibility he's had
months five priorities but yeah so what
I mean he boasts about previous Tory
achievements we've got to deal with the
country as it is now its previous Tory
governments that caused the problem this
Tory government consulted out Richie
sunax failure is not to take
responsibility he's had 10 12 days of us
telling him some ideas that he could
pick up right now he's failed to I'm
judging him on his actions just just one
final set of questions on what we saw
take place at the weekend with with the
Grand National we spoke just a few
minutes ago to the chief executive of
the Jockey Club who was very explicit in
saying we will not be able to prevent
this from happening that there is always
an element of risk embracing events of
this type of particularly in racing
events of this type what do you make of
that well look I know that the Grand
National is a Great British institution
and it's loved by the people of
merseyside and we really saw that the
weekend however when the rspca says that
there is a cause for concern and a need
for review we've got to take that
seriously I I I really want to see that
review the rspca is calling for and I
think it would be the right thing to do
the Grand National History yeah and what
purpose would a review have given that
you know this this is not you I'm not
the expert but I do also know that the
Carnage of previous Decades of the Grand
National we've moved a long way from
that but it's never going to be okay for
us we're never going to feel okay are we
We're a nation of animal lovers seeing
the death of three horses in even in a
Great British institution like the Grand
National is going to hurt people and I
think the rsbc are right to call for
review and I look forward to seeing what
that's got to say I'm sure you are not
alone in that uh thank you good to have
you on the program